So we're going to test out that knowledge by having you submit
via the interpreter, as a quiz--
some parsing rules that are going to handle a real part of JavaScript.
Now, a lot like Python, JavaScript allows function calls--
you write out the name of your function
and then you just pass in some number of arguments,
possibly none.
For that particular function, we would want the parse tree
to be a tuple.
That's how we're representing parse trees.
The first part is "call"--telling us that it's a call expression.
The next part is the name of the function,
and then there's a list of all of the arguments.
And this list may be empty if there are no arguments
or it may contain expression parse trees.
And, in fact, I'll do the first and second parts for you.
Here's a rule for making expressions
that are function calls:
That's an identifier, like "myfun",
followed by a Left parenthesis,
followed by some optional arguments,
followed by a Right parenthesis.
And we just build up our parse tree
out of a tuple--the word "call",
the identifier--that's p[1]--zero, 1, 2, 3, 4--
and the optional arguments are position[3]--
I definitely need the (p) there--there we go: p[3].
Similarly, our rule for expressions that could be numbers,
expression can become a number, at which point,
I just make up this tuple, "number", followed by the actual value.
and that's how we got things like this
for ("number", 11).
So here's the quiz: I'd like you to fill in the value
for parsing optional arguments,
and you may find that you have to define
a few more of these parsing rules--
maybe some for there being no argument,
some for there being at least one, and that kind of thing--try it out.